so i'll tell you what we get from this
i mentioned this you know when i did my
algorithmic psychosis rant you know last
week or whatever
that people end up growing up living in
this world where the only news they get
is that all cops are bad
all cops are racist and it's because
like you said ian they're looking in
there they're looking in this far this
vast ocean and they see this one tiny
dot
and it's the only thing they're showing
to people check out this story from the
daily mail
minnesota 4th graders are given equity
survey on race and gender
and are told by teacher not to skip
questions even if they don't understand
them
and not to tell their parents let me
just show you one of the questions
number 46 do you currently identify
yourself as female male transgender
transgender people have a gender
identity or gender expression that
differs from their assigned sex
for example they were born male but now
identify as female or something else
and you can choose female male
transgender non-binary
why is a fourth grader being told to
first of all out themselves the teachers
should
they actually have a you know a trans or
non-binary identity
why why are the kids being handed this
stuff on equity in this survey
given these questions what i think is
these teachers
likely millennials grew up getting
exposed to the social media over the
past 10 years
nothing but extremist content that
generated rage
their whole world view was built on it
and now they're giving it to the kids
they are transferring that tenfold to
children
who are not going to have the same
opportunity to have
you know millennials didn't completely
grow up on the internet to a great deal
they did but i know a lot of people who
didn't get internet until they were late
teenagers
at least it's some opportunity to use a
phone mounted to the wall you know touch
tone phone
word yeah yeah right yeah it took you
ten minutes to write one paragraph these
little kids are not only going to grow
up on social media
being inundated with nothing but
critical race applied principles
but they're going to be getting it from
their teachers as well and you know what
i can't remember i can't remember who it
was i should i should write down the
quotes but someone on the show said
parents don't care about their children
at all
and it's because and the example is that
they're being sent off to
institutionalized learning facilities
where the parents don't know what
they're being taught
don't know what they're being exposed to
and to a great deal don't care
a lot of parents do care steve bannon's
bet is that come august 15th when the
parents find out what's going on
they're going to lose it but i think
it's a really good point if you think
about it
parents say i'm gonna send my kids to
school
and then hope for the best now by all
means i understand some people may have
normalized this behavior
some people probably get really offended
by me saying the saying tim you don't
have kids you know you're talking about
but i can say this if you are not at the
very least actively asking your children
what is going on at school show me your
assignments show me your books
then i don't think you really care what
strength spending time with them
god forbid well yeah but that's like
obviously if you care about your kids to
spend time with them what i'm saying is
i get it send your kids to school i
think there's issues i think you should
homeschool i think we should do more
more of the pod learning
i was homeschooled quite a bit i think
if you were really concerned about what
schools were doing to your kids
you'd for one be very you'd pay a whole
lot of attention to the school boards
you'd pay attention to the school
curriculums and a lot of parents do
i think a lot of parents don't and
that's probably why they're they're the
more lefty democrat voters don't you're
saying though
like don't you see pushback in american
society right now against what you're
talking about
and like this goes back to what we're
saying critical theory is a critique
right
what do you mean by pushback well i'm
saying all the
school board meetings that are going
viral and you know all these parents and
these kids and
teachers speaking out and the way in
which you know
this whole concept of critical theory is
a big critic
how many conversation right now how many
important i agree how many school board
battles
are there right now well that's how the
tide turns though it's like
you know we're at high tide right now
and it's shifting do you know how many
school board battles there are
i don't know i'm not trying to put you
on the spot i'm genuinely asking if
you're familiar because
i don't have the answer uh i have a
general asset it's a good question i
mean we run them all the time because i
think it's
you know it's a it's a government feed
so you can it's non-commercialized so
you can just run it as is
have you have you guys seen any hard
numbers and how many school boards are
in
i've seen one article that mentioned it
was like between six and seven hundred
school boards are enrolled how many are
there in like total
there are 85 uh i'm sorry 98
271 public grade schools as of
between 2013 and 2014. 98 000.
so we hear these stories and we're like
the parents are fighting back
yes at how many schools
out of the nearly 100 000 schools
are the kids the kids are all being
indoctrinated i tell you this right now
that fourth grader is what nine years
old yeah nine more years until she votes
for a marxist
if you're a teacher and you're telling
the kids not to talk to their parents
you are enacting child abuse that kid
has a right and a duty to communicate
with its parents
if you're a parent ask your kid what
they learned at school today but that's
exactly what they're doing
we saw that it's like you're lying to me
people are
not encourage your kids to lie to their
parents i think parents don't care about
their kids
why would you think that because what
you've been told lately
i was homeschooled i was i was
homeschooled
before kindergarten and then i went to
i went to a private catholic school
until the end of fifth grade
my parents transferred me to public
school for a few years my grades slipped
a little bit then
uh in the first few months of high
school my parents
asked what was going on and when they
saw the negative impacts they
immediately pulled us out
and homeschooled us again because my
parents genuinely in my opinion
cared and they sent us to school because
it's you know school i mean it's what
you do
but they were always very active we
would we were going when we were at
catholic school we were going to mass
and then when we stopped when when we
switched to public school there was a
lot less
family interaction with with the school
system but the reason i think i would
say parents don't care about their kids
is that how often have you heard of the
trope where the kid says my teacher
hates me and the parent says oh
shut up geez you've heard that trope
before right you know it's like
no it's not fair my teacher hates me oh
come on you're just not doing your work
the the the point where parents don't
trust their own children when they say
i'm having problems in school
not every parent does this i'm not
saying every single parent i'm saying
there are many parents who are like go
to school i have no
idea what they're telling you i have no
idea what you're learning i have no idea
if you're going to be a good a good
person
or you're going to hold my values or
have a good life i have no idea what
goes on in that building for those eight
hours or whatever you're there
i bet it has to do with stress you know
how they say if someone goes out and
works 12-hour days and they're exhausted
when they get home
they have no time to talk about politics
they only care about where the food is
and that's it the basic life so if the
parent is stressed about money and
they're working a job
two jobs that can't really even pay the
bills they're going to be too stressed
or have this layer of stress that's
interfering with their communication
with their kids
they are using school as daycare yes
that is not a good thing this is a
problem
i mean but you know don't you think that
our like the public school system
wasn't exactly like rosie before this
yeah it's like based around a factory
there's literally like a bell that's
like yeah
go to the next class so like what kind
of i agree no
is that the kind of environment that's
going to create a critical thinking
individual
no but i encourage the employees of tim
cass to bring their kids to work
as often as they can and they'll uh they
can hang out and you know
just you gotta have some parenting don't
let them spill milk on the carpet or
something like that
but i not not only was i homeschooled
but when my mom opened a coffee shop on
the north side of chicago
which look you know we were like a lower
middle class family and this was like
very devastating for my family in terms
of loans it didn't work and then we went
you know my family got bankrupt and
stuff like that
but when when my mom opened a coffee
house i was nine years old and i had to
go work there
so i was sitting around next to a bunch
of adults talking politics i was getting
exposed to the real world
so it's been treating you like an adult
they're not treated like oh hello little
guy we need to cuddle you
right you know they were treating me
like an adult and to an extent
they were treating like an adult you
know it's like when you're working they
would they wouldn't be like
oh it's so cute that you're trying to
wash the dishes they'd be like can you
finish the dishes because we've got a
bunch of waters coming in we need these
mugs you know what though
that can go overboard because i'm just
laughing as you're saying this because
um
you want to know why i always super glue
myself instead of getting stitches and
going to the hospital
it's because when i was like six years
old my dad was like all right let's go
do my week on rounds at the hospital
with this guy i'll never forget i walk
into this room and the guy's like in a
full
um cast like his whole body it was like
like almost like out of a cartoon like
his arms are in a full cast he's like
all the way up to his neck he's like hey
doc how are you doing
hold on one sec rich i got this guy an
industrial uh air conditioner fell on
him
he's like i feel great amazing two days
like i never want to go to the hospital
that was it for me i i the socialization
that i got growing up
was very much from a lot of adults in
the workplace
like real world interactions and so i
look at what's happening to
previous generations kids the current
generations kids i mean think about this
what do kids need to be exposed to to
live good healthy fulfilling lives
they need to understand how to lead good
healthy fulfilling lives
but we have kids raise each other the
parents take the kid
and they put them in the school the
teacher mindlessly drones along
with like you know half glazed over eyes
going turn up and seven and the kids
are sharing notes with each other the
kids are all raising each other man
it's no surprise to me that we're seeing
cultural decay when millennials
in many ways grew up going to schools
where the teachers
mostly don't care about them their
parents mostly don't know what's going
on in these schools
the kids are going out to parties and
teaching each other things
so yeah you get like a lord of the flies
type scenario these kids grow up they
get power and then it's just like who's
got the conch bashing people over the
head
i grew up surrounded by people working
jobs and working in businesses and
i'm here i am running a business you
know
it's funny you say that because i i got
major lord of the flies vibes when i was
in the jazz
it was like the kids leading the kids
yeah exactly and it was and that's why
they don't understand what work is where
money comes from
they're just like i swear i was i was
arguing with people
who who are pro-ubi and i gave the
simple argument of
if you don't make stuff there is no
stuff and they were like
what are you talking about like there's
stuff in stores
and then i was like yeah but somebody
had to make that stuff and they're like
what do you mean it's just there
and i was like no way dude what are you
legit telling me you don't know what
supply chain is
i actually had an argument with someone
who told me the electricity was just
there in the walls
that's actually mark levin he has a
great
um i forget which book it is he's
written so many so many books
um but he he basically he tracks the
supply chain of a pencil
that's cool it's a graphic pencil and
how complex how many
different sources of manufacturers etc
and how hard it is
to collectivize that and centrally plan
it rather than just allow basically the
marketplace to figure out how to make
that supply chain work
you can't centralize it that's why
communism doesn't work
but you look at these young people what
happens they're placed in
institutionalized learning facilities by
their parents without a thought
they then have a teacher who tells them
what to do and when they do it and they
say okay
the food it's food time they walk in the
room and there's food
and then they go home their whole lives
and you've got people who go to school
until what 22 or 24
their entire lives some of these kids
never had a job in their life
they have no idea what production is so
when they get out of school they're
simply like
where is the authority figure telling me
what to do and giving me food
so they demand the government do it and
that's they're voting for right now
and if parents wanted their kids to be
successful to be able to survive to have
their values
they would be communicating with them
every day they'd be working with them
and and very much to a great degree
taking them out of these schools
when you get these four-year-olds who
are being given these these cult surveys
about creepy stuff
you shouldn't be asking kids or there
was that one teacher who was
playing the video for kids about how to
you know take care of business on your
own
we keep it family friendly i guess how
do you irk it
yeah yes yes huh it wasn't a how-to it
was just a
this happens to occur oh you're talking
about that cartoon yeah
yeah that was creepy right it was really
weird but think about the parents
think about the parents who are like i
had no idea they were doing it to my
kids
now when parents found out about it they
freaked out well plus don't you think
it's also i don't know there's a certain
corruptive factor of having the internet
like literally hear that
you know if we're talking about lord of
the flies the loss of innocence that
happens to a ten-year-old kid the moment
that they go to the website that their
buddy told
like i had to download it off napster i
was like all right four days later i got
this
like dude you know video of me or
whatever i stole this song that has
swears in it you know early 90s
compuserve and it's like
this song will download in 14 hours
and like that's your that's your moment
of loss of innocence south america it's
still two kilobits a second
in the jungle not with
have you ever seen the time machine the
movie yeah
or read the book i read the book yeah
you know how like he goes to the far
future and there's like the one super
intelligent guy and then a bunch of the
like cavemen
and they're two distinct species now
yeah that's basically what's happening
you look at these tech elites
the foods they eat the way they live
their lives the things they have access
to
and the things regular people do the way
they live their life live their lives
and what they have access to
it really just feels like take a look at
their kids the children of the tech
elites do not have phones or internet
tablets they don't give it to them i
wonder why mark zuckerberg
takes the camera and microphone on his
computer he knows it's in the sausage
that's right it's like it's like they
know soylent green is people
everybody else is eating it with a smile
on their face they're like don't look at
me i'm not eating that stuff i don't
want encephalopathy or whatever
encephalitis whatever it's called i mean
i think that's that's what can be taken
i mean that's what i take from the last
year which is like
you see the the everything that we're
talking about right now it manifests
itself on the streets with these sad
desperate people who are out there
because they're desperate
and whatever side of the political
spectrum they're on they're desperate
because they feel like the system has
failed them
and probably because it has and nobody's
addressing that nobody's addressing the
actual
everybody says it's either systemic
racism or it's cancel culture but
nobody's like
whoa hold on this is just two different
hands of the same issue here
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at 8
pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time